(clicking)
(electronic chiming)
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to A Conversation
With History, I'm Harry Kreisler
at the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Sherry Turkle,
who is the Abby Rockefeller Mauze
professor of social studies,
of science and technology,
in the Program in Science Technology,
and Society at the Massachusets
Institute of Technology.
She's a prolific writer, and
has published many books,
including Life on the Screen:
Identity in the age of the Internet,
Alone Together: Why we
Expect More from Technology
and Less From Each Other.
And most recently,
Reclaiming Conversation:
The Power of Talk in a Digital Age.
Sherry, welcome to Berkeley.
- My pleasure.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Brooklyn, New York.
And that's where I was raised.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- I think they had a pretty
insular view of the world,
I think that they didn't
really live much past Brooklyn.
And I think that they
shaped my view of the world
'cause I so desperately wanted to get out.
So I think that they shaped me
by encouraging me to follow that dream.
- And your interest in
psychology and identity,
did that come as an undergraduate, later,
or was it something that developed
when you were still at home?
- I think that's so interesting,
I think I was always very introspective
trying to understand my family culture.
I'm writing a memoir now
about growing up in Brooklyn,
about my family.
So I think I was very interested in
my family culture and
the people around me,
so probably I've always
been very introspective
but I think certainly as an undergraduate,
I studied with Erik Erikson,
who was about identity,
I remember Erik Erikson,
I remember thinking he looked like God.
He had this sort of white hair, and--
- And he was very
influential in that time.
- Very influential.
- You're at Harvard
in the '60s, or Radcliffe,
and then Harvard in the '60s.
- Yes, and he used to walk
the campus with his wife,
and I mean, people used to
say, look, Mr. and Mrs. God,
I mean he really had that aura.
And he taught a course on
identity in the life cycle
and I sat in on that
course for three years
just listening to him talk about
identity in the life cycle.
- And we'll talk about some
of your books in a minute,
but they're written with great clarity,
and writing skill,
when did this concern,
focus, and craft writing,
come to you, over time,
did you develop that
in high school and in college?
- I was the editor of my,
but probably I should've
answered your question about identity
by talking about being editor
of my high school newspaper.
I think I saw myself as a writer,
in high school, before I
saw myself as an academic,
or knew anything about being an academic,
I think that I was confirmed an idea
that I would be a writer in high school.
Because I just, it was the thing I loved.
I mean, I just, I didn't know
that women could be academics.
Even in college, there were
really no tenured professors
at Harvard, I went to Radcliffe,
which you studied with
the Harvard faculty,
there were no tenured women
on the Harvard faculty.
I never had a woman as a professor
the whole time I was there.
I'm not sure I knew that
that was a day job for girls.
But I knew that there were women writers,
and I think I saw myself as a writer
before I thought of myself as an academic.
So the idea that I
would work on my writing
and craft my writing,
and rewrite, and rewrite,
is certainly something that
from the very beginning
was of interest to me.
And I really do, when people say,
when my students say to me,
oh, you're such a good writer,
I always say to them, well,
you're reading the 30th draft.
So writing is editing,
and I try to teach that to
my students that that's the trick.
- So was it an easy journey
from Brooklyn to Radcliffe?
- No, no!
(both laughing)
No, I went to a high
school where my guidance,
where no one from my high school
went to Ivy League schools,
it was very unusual.
I was told that to do that, you
had to be the valedictorian.
And so that was very hard
to be the valedictorian,
I think there were 1500 people
in the graduating class,
so it was a job.
And I was valedictorian, I
was very fortunate, and I--
- In high school.
- In high school, right.
I got to go, but it was actually quite,
it was really a job to
get that accomplished.
But I was, you know, I'm
sure I would've got in
to a good school if I'd been number two,
or three, or four, or five,
but it was actually,
it was actually a task.
- Besides Erikson, who were your mentors
or your great influencers in
your undergraduate education?
- Barrington Moore, who
was a great Marxist.
Stanley Hoffmann, who ignited my study
of France and French intellectual life,
which I wrote my first book on France
and that was very influenced
by studying with Stanley Hoffmann.
Laurence Wylie, another
scholar of French life.
George Homans, a sociologist at Harvard
who was very important to me.
Marty Peretz, who was the chairman
of the social studies department,
which was my undergraduate major.
I had many mentors, I was very fortunate,
I really had many...
David Riesman, a student
of American culture.
There was a lot of, I was
very fortunate in that
I was at Harvard at a time when...
There was a lot of political ferment
but also a lot of tension
paid to undergraduate teaching
and to undergraduate majors.
I had a great undergraduate
experience, I really did.
I was very, very fortunate.
- Was it the times that
made you so voracious a student,
or was it something that
came from your background?
- Well, you know, I went there ready to,
I mean, I went there ready to learn.
(both laugh)
- Absorb--
- I was like, I'm here,
you know, so I mean I wanna
give myself full credit
that I kinda got there ready to go.
But I think it was also the times.
I mean I think that it
was very political times,
so I wanted to, you know,
Marx, Weber, Durkheim, Freud,
I mean, everything was relevant
to thinking about politics,
to thinking about how
did people absorb ideas,
what ideas were important,
what ideas could help you
think through American culture?
You know, the world, I
was lit to understand
what was happening, and I
didn't understand anything.
And people felt that great ideas,
I think this is perhaps
the difference from now
is that people around me felt that history
would help me understand
what was happening.
- And that ideas mattered.
And I'm not sure that now,
when people try to understand
our current dilemma,
people wanna go to Marx,
Weber, Durkheim, Freud,
I mean, I was in a group of people
where that was the first
thing that occurred to us
was to try to understand our dilemma
by going to history, by going
to sociology to create ideas.
- You then went to France,
now, was this--
- Yes.
- Before you graduated?
- Yes, it was an interesting
convergence of things.
I had a personal difficulty,
my mom died when I was in college.
My mother died, and I was in no state.
I couldn't study, I couldn't work,
I needed to take a break.
I had been studying French
politics and society
and I went to France, I
dropped out of school,
I worked as a cleaning lady in France.
And I went to Sciences Po,
so I was a kind of cleaning lady student.
While there, I was there
just after the May Days,
and I observed something
that would turn out
to be quite fateful for my later work,
I observed that people who had
been active in the May Days
were starting to kind of converge towards
getting interested in psychoanalysis,
but not any psychoanalysis,
the psychoanalysis of Jacques Lacan,
which was kind of unusual
because in America
the people who were interested in politics
did not kind of trend
towards the psychoanalysis,
on the contrary, people who
were interested in politics
thought that psychoanalytic things
was kind of moving away from politics
towards an interest in the self,
those two trends were very different.
Because I was interested in Freud,
and that was a very different track
than being interested in politics.
- And what was different about it?
- Well, that was the question for me,
what was there about Jacques Lacan,
and his brand of psychoanalysis,
that people felt that moving
from politics to psychoanalysis
was kind of doing the same thing.
And that question, what was
this politically acceptable
psychoanalysis became the
theme of my first book
because then, when I came back to Harvard
to do a PhD in sociology and psychology,
the subject of my dissertation
was psychoanalytic politics,
became my first book
which was really what was
the mystery, this intellectual
history of mystery
of what was there about
the Lacanian movement
that had made this slippage
from politics to psychoanalysis possible,
what was this infatuation with Freud
that had made this a kind
of political psychoanalysis.
- And did that slippage
make politics interesting,
and did it offer explanatory
power for these mass movements?
- Well, it offered a political
language for psychoanalysis,
the communist party became
interested in Lacan,
it offered a political
language to psychoanalysis
and it offered a way to make,
to think about politics
in a psychological way.
You know, I think it...
I think people sensed
that it wasn't the moment
for a political revolution in France
and they wanted to
continue to think about,
they wanted a way to think about the self
in a way that was politicized.
And the Lacanian movement provided that.
And it was a very interesting time,
and I interviewed psychoanalysts,
I interviewed political people,
but what really was
very fascinating for me
and that then provided a
transition to my later work
is I became interested in the idea of
not the psychoanalytic movement,
but the psychoanalytic culture.
That is to say, what happens
to psychoanalytic ideas
when they sort of hit the street
and they're no longer the
ideas of the intelligentsia
but they're the ideas that people use
really in everyday life.
You know, what happens to ideas not
as they're elaborated by intellectuals
but as they're brought into
people's sort of everyday lives.
And that became important to me
because when I began to study
artificial intelligence,
I wasn't interested in these ideas
as they were developed in seminar rooms,
but as they came down and hit the street
when people began to
use ideas from computers
to talk about their own minds
and their children's minds,
you know, kind of as
ideas from computation
became embedded in everyday life,
when people had personal computers.
So that notion of a
sociology of sciences of mind
as we pick it up in everyday life
really became my academic,
kind of my academic identity.
And so there was a kind of,
even though the topics changed
from psychoanalysis to computer culture,
that sort of became my thing.
- You are a sociologist, a psychologist,
that winds up sorta
focusing on the cyber world.
- Yes.
- And what it's doing to us.
I like to ask my guests about
the skillset and the temperament
that is at the heart of their work.
With the possibility of, you know,
advising students about how they prepare
for their own future.
- Well, what I would say
is that when I started out,
I'd looked like I was very confused
because I needed to learn
how to be a sociologist,
because I needed to learn about
Durkheim and Weber and Marx
and how to think about
large social movements.
But I needed, really I felt,
to learn how to be a clinician,
how to learn how to do
clinical interviews,
I'm trained as a psychoanalyst as well.
I felt I needed a clinical degree.
So I looked like somebody who
was a little bit all over the place.
And I felt very conflicted about that
because other people were
either going to law school
or they were going to getting
a degree in political science,
I was jealous of them
because they looked so,
they looked so, I don't
know, so organized.
And I went to Chicago to the
Committee on Social Thought
and then I went to Harvard
and I got a sociology degree,
and then I said no, I also
need a clinical degree,
I mean, I just, I got a joint degree
in personality psychology and sociology
and then I got clinical accreditation
and I mean, I did a
lot of degrees (laughs)
I did a lot of things.
So I think that my advice would be
I needed, I just needed
these different skillsets
and I just got these different skillsets.
And I just did to get
them one after another
and I just would say to students
who feel that they need
a couple of skillsets,
relax, you know, you're
gonna feel a little,
you may feel a little greedy,
or a little disorganized,
and you'll be jealous of
people who seem more organized.
But if you feel that your
intellectual identity
depends on getting these
different skillsets,
if you can afford it, you know,
I had to work jobs, and it
took me a little longer,
you know, just put one
foot in front of the other.
And so I sort of am glad
you asked me this question
because I think that actually I did feel,
I don't wanna say I felt guilty
but I felt bad about myself because other,
I felt envious of other people
who seemed more, you know, organized.
- And I wanna just ask you,
did you know where you were
going with all of this,
or was it just that you were excited
about what you could learn?
- I knew that I needed,
I had this idea of this
intimate ethnography,
that's how I thought about it.
That I wanted to do, it seemed
to me that I wanted to do
a kind of ethnographic work,
where you interviewed people,
and you were on the ground in
a kind of ethnographic setting
but it seemed to me the kind
of interviewing I wanted to do,
to ask somebody for example
about why they were in psychoanalysis
when they had just been
in political action.
That the kind of interview that required
was actually quite intimate.
I mean, the questions were not like,
you know, with your microphone,
you know, it was a very
intimate interview, because...
You know, asking why they
were in psychoanalysis,
I mean, that took a long time,
you couldn't ask it directly,
you had to befriend them,
they had to trust you.
You know, they were maybe gonna tell you
very intimate things and
there would be talking
about the failure of
this political movement
and how they felt about that,
but now they were in psychoanalysis
and they weren't gonna say
they were in psychoanalysis
'cause the political movement failed,
I mean, it was gonna be a
very, you needed skills.
And I saw that I didn't have those skills.
So to get better at that kind of thing
I needed to really develop skills.
And the more clinical skills I had,
the better I got at it.
So, I felt that I needed to
really work on clinical skills.
And I developed this notion in my mind
of intimate ethnography
with clinical skills.
And so that, I would say
that was my guiding idea.
And once I had that guiding idea,
well, things fell into place.
- When you look at your works,
two things stand out for me.
Not the only two things, but
a way to approach your work.
One is what you chose to study,
and we'll talk about that in a minute,
but the other is your
philosophical perspective
and that seems to be focused on
what makes us human, our humanness,
talk a little about that,
does that emerge out of this
extraordinary education?
Does it inform our understanding
of what it is you're doing?
- Well, I think that my
concern about the human
really has come out of my study of
computer culture, working with people who
are so often saying that
we don't need to be human.
I mean, (laughing) I remember,
I'm just writing a memoir now
and in my work, I have
already cited this story
of Marvin Minsky, and
going with Marvin Minsky
to a showing of the movie Tron,
Marvin Minsky is a great AI,
artificial intelligence, hero.
- Is this the same Minsky
who was an economist?
- No, he's an artificial
intelligence guru.
- Okay.
- He's one of
the founders of artificial intelligence
and together we see the movie Tron,
which is a movie about the brain
and how the brain is made
up of a society of programs
and it's a very AI movie.
And we come out of the movie,
and of course Minsky's very excited
and we're there with all of his students
and we're all talking about his movie
as kind of an embodiment of his idea,
his idea's called the society of mind,
and the mind is made up
of embodied programs.
And Marvin and I get into a conversation
and he says, you know,
no children should see them,
all children should see this movie
'cause it teaches how the
mind is made up of programs,
no children, children
should see this movie
and they shouldn't see the movie Bambi.
(Harry laughs)
And I said, you know, I love Bambi,
why shouldn't they see Bambi?
Because Bambi teaches that
you attach to a mother
and in the future, we're all
gonna be embodied in computers
and there should be no attachment,
we're never gonna die 'cause we're gonna
embody ourselves in computers,
it's the wrong message
because we shouldn't
be teaching about death
and we're not gonna die, we're
just gonna become computers,
there should be no attachment to mothers
and he's off on this
we're not gonna be human,
we're gonna be embodied in computer.
This is MIT, this is my lot.
So I think that I became like, very,
are you kidding me, no mothers,
we're gonna go into computers?
You know, it's like (laughs) I became like
very team human, you know?
Kind of surrounded by people who
either we were gonna graduate
and become computers,
we're gonna become embodied in computers,
we're gonna become linked to computers.
So I think that I became,
and then one of his students
told me that Minsky wanted,
I was interviewing this student
and the student said, well,
Minsky wants to create
a computer that a soul
would wanna live in.
I mean, I was surrounded by a culture
where we were either gonna marry computers
or graduate, evolve into computers,
so I think that I very
early in my time at MIT
started to think about, well,
what was essential about being human?
And I think that that
became, as I began to study
children in computers, smart machines,
children responding to smart machines.
The question of what was
essential about being human
became something that
was just like in my face
to start thinking about.
So it wasn't like I went
into it with this as my,
I wasn't particularly
trained as a philosopher,
I mean, I'm totally out
of my depth actually.
It wasn't like my philosophical,
it wasn't where I came
from, philosophically.
But very early on in my,
and literally on the
ground what I was studying
these children talking
about what was special
about being human, it's what
I started to think about.
Surrounded by these people
who couldn't tolerate
the movie Bambi 'cause
it was too sentimental
about humanity.
- How did you wind up at MIT,
was that a choice about
studying this cyber--
- No, no no no, no,
I was in Cambridge,
I was writing, no, it
was totally an accident.
I was in Cambridge, and I
wanted to turn my dissertation,
I had written my French Freud dissertation
and it was, the dissertation was done,
but I wanted to turn it into a book
and so I really wasn't ready to take
an assistant professorship job.
And MIT offered me
a kind of year,
what was like a research fellowship
and they said we have
this research fellowship
in this new program called
Science, Technology, and Society.
And at the end of the year,
if you wanna be an assistant professor,
there's a job for you in this new program.
But for the year, there's no teaching,
you just have to turn your
dissertation into a book.
And I thought, well that's a great,
you know, that's a great
deal, just by accident,
but I hadn't, computers
were 100% not on my mind
I just wanted to turn my
dissertation on Jacques Lacan
into a book.
But when I was there, I
discovered the world of computer,
I mean, just like, it was all around me.
And I saw the, I don't
wanna say the similarities
'cause that's not strong enough.
The analogy between artificial
intelligence, psychoanalysis,
the science of mind that was now
coming into the popular culture
carried by an object.
The difference between psychoanalysis
and artificial intelligence
was very dramatic
because psychoanalysis is
carried into the popular culture
by writings or dreams, I mean,
I argue that they're objects
that carry psychoanalysis
into popular culture.
The fact that we talk about our dreams
using a psychoanalytic language
is a way that it's carried
into popular culture.
But the computer stuff was being carried
into popular culture by this new object,
the computer language being
carried into popular culture
by this new object, and I came to MIT
just at the moment when personal computers
were starting to be in popular culture.
Literally 1976 was the year of
the first personal computers.
And I just lucked out.
I shouldn't say I lucked out,
because I mean, I had to see it.
I mean, I had to you know, I saw it.
I saw it.
I just saw it.
- Explain this a little more about the,
in other words, computers
were an object to study.
- Yes, I call it an evocative object.
- Okay, and why are they important?
Because they--
- They carry these new ideas,
in other words, at MIT at the time,
it was artificial intelligence,
this new science that's thinking
about the mind as a machine.
There was this new kind of
thinking called cognitive science
which was, again, thinking
about the mind as a machine,
that the human memory could be analogized
to the memory in a computer.
So the birth of cognitive science,
the birth of artificial intelligence,
these new sciences of mind that were
thinking about the mind in machine terms.
And these new ways of
thinking about the mind
which now we think of as so natural,
we think of the mind as a machine,
were now gonna be coming
into the culture, I thought,
because at the same time as
they were being discussed
in seminar rooms and laboratories,
Texas Instruments or RadioShack,
or Apple, you know not yet Apple,
but the people in garages
that I was learning about
were building personal computers
that were gonna be starting
to come into the culture
as objects.
And in 1976, I could start to see that,
you could start to see that
all of this was starting.
'76, '77, '78, all of that
was starting to happen.
- And in the beginning and
in your first book on this,
you were more positive about
the impact of these objects
coming into the culture.
Talk a little about that,
I mean, what was great about it then?
- Well, because...
You had a new science of mind,
a new way of reflecting on the self,
that was, I called the
children who were meeting
computer toys for the first time,
met them, and began talking,
like I called them child philosophers,
they started talking,
these new objects provoked
thinking about the self.
You know, children would
meet these new objects
and they would start to talk about, well,
these objects are programmed,
I wonder if I'm programmed?
And they would start to reflect on, well,
this is a programmed thing,
I wonder if I'm programmed,
and they would start to talk about
the nature of being programmed.
And I'm not exaggerating, I mean,
they were just like anybody would
if they said, well, this
thing is programmed,
I wonder if I'm programmed,
or they would start to really talk about,
and also you have to remember
that in the early days,
children programmed computers,
you couldn't work these computers
unless you programmed them
so all children were programmers.
So my first book on these objects,
there are chapters and
chapters on child programmers
because when children met these computers
the only, you couldn't
work with the computers
unless you programmed the computers.
So no computers came with
stuff to do with them
unless you programmed them.
So everybody who had a
computer programmed a computer.
So the things you did with computers
involved your learning
to think like a computer
and your getting involved
in computational thinking,
and so it was like watching people learn
a new way of thinking about, well,
maybe the mind works like that,
I wonder what it is to
think like a computer,
I wonder if I think like a computer,
I wonder if people have
always thought like computers,
or what is it to think like a computer?
So I was very positive about
the kinds of conversations
about mind
that were happening in the culture
just as I had been very excited about,
I wasn't particularly for or against them,
that's not my place, but just as I'd been
very excited about the kinds
of conversations about mind
that were happening in France,
when people were dialoguing
about psychoanalysis
as an exciting thing to watch.
- So at this stage, computers were a tool
that in service of the human mind--
- Yes.
- And the human--
- It provoked thinking.
- Yeah.
- And then what happened
is they became black boxed
and they became...
They became like games, I mean,
they became closed down and they became
something that you sort
of no longer were open
for that kind of thinking,
they became just sort of shut down and
not transparent anymore, but opaque,
and no longer were kind of
available to most people
for that kind of reflection.
The nature of what computer
culture meant changed.
- So you fortunately wound up in a place
where what you were surrounded by
and what you came to study
was changing over time.
- Yes, and what I did
was I studied that shift.
I studied that shift from
transparency to opacity
in the nature of these objects,
and actually that was the
topic of kind of my next books,
were really marking that shift
from transparency to opacity,
and the nature of the computer culture.
And that was, I think,
my contribution has been
to talk about that shift,
and really to document
the inner life of how the computer culture
has changed our inner life,
because now we're deeply
enmeshed in a computer culture
that no longer is that
kind of evocative object
for those sorts of issues.
Now, we use the computer
for very different things
and the issues that it brings
up are very different for us.
Now I'm onto a whole
different set of issues
when I talk about the computer.
- So the next stage is really confronting,
what shall we call it, the
Bambi moment essentially?
(laughing)
Which is to say, why not Bambi?
So what's intriguing about
what you're saying is
it wasn't the extraordinary
education so much
as the reality that you were confronting
that made you more and more sensitive
to our loss of humanity.
- Well, I mean--
- Or, diminishing of the--
- I mean, I think that you know,
that studying the computer culture at MIT,
I mean I studied the changes in what
computers have confronted us
with changing opportunities
and changing challenges.
So right now, I mean,
the challenges that they confront
us with are considerable.
Right now the challenges
are to our privacy,
to our democracy, to our sense of self.
Are we happy with the notion
of evolving with computers
to a different place,
people talk about kind of
co-evolution with computers,
is that something we're comfortable with?
The challenges Facebook poses
to democracy and privacy,
that's a different kind of challenge.
I mean, there are so many things
that we're confronted with now
but there's also the, you know.
Given my background, I'm
particularly interested in
what I call artificial intimacy.
I mean, you know.
We have computers that can
pretend to be psychotherapists,
that can have a
conversation with you about
you know, your love life, your feelings,
your spouse, your children.
I mean the fact that it can pretend,
the fact that a computer can pretend
or be good enough to fake intimacy
doesn't mean that it's capable
of intimacy or empathy.
And I think that's a,
you know, this as-if intimacy and empathy,
people need to sort out
whether that's good enough
to be the real thing.
So I'm trying to spark a
conversation about that.
- One of two of the core ideas
that you latch onto,
develop, one is solitude.
- Yes.
- Talk a little about that,
because you see solitude as key to the
development and maturation
of the individuals
so that they can go out
and confront the world.
- Yes, so in my, in
Reclaiming Conversation,
I talk about two things.
I try to organize my
ideas, saying you know,
there are two things that are lost
in our recent fascination with our phones.
Our heads in our phones.
And one is is that people are becoming
less capable of being bored.
We're losing the capacity for boredom,
and the capacity to be bored
is an incredibly important
developmental moment,
and it's so important because boredom,
when you're feeling bored,
your brain is not bored at all,
your brain is laying down
what's called the default mode network,
which is the pathways for the development
of a stable sense of an
autobiographical self.
So you need those moments
when you feel bored
for your brain really to develop
your stable sense of self.
Right now when people feel bored,
they have no tolerance and they go
immediately to their phones.
So the first thing is I try to argue,
you know, remind people of the importance
of those moments of boredom and say,
you know, walk towards boredom.
Make sure your child doesn't
have a phone in front of them.
'Cause there are potty trainers
with slots for an iPhone
and slots for an iPad, no, no, no.
And baby bouncers where you
can put an iPad or an iPhone,
no, no, you know, let your child be bored.
Let them develop that capacity.
So boredom is very
important, and with boredom,
comes the capacity for solitude.
Now, why is solitude, these
go together very often
because very often in solitude
we need to have that moment of boredom,
you know, why is solitude so important?
Because the capacity for solitude
means you're alone with yourself,
you can tolerate your own company,
you know your own company,
which means that when
you go to somebody else,
because you're okay with yourself,
you can then recognize
them for who they are.
You're not trying to use who they are
to buttress your fragile
sense of yourself,
you're okay with yourself
so you can recognize another person.
So it's actually very
important to know who you are
and be okay with who you are,
in order to recognize someone
else for who they are.
The two really go together.
We forget that, we forget
the importance of solitude
for relational purposes.
And we have to remember the importance
of solitude for relational purposes.
So the psychoanalytic
tradition is so important here
because the great
psychoanalyst David Winnicott,
and here I paraphrase, said you know,
if you don't teach your
children to be lonely,
children to be alone,
they'll only know how to be lonely.
Which is, I think, one
of the great insights
from the psychoanalytic tradition
which people throw out
much too quickly now.
You need to know how to be alone
in order to be not lonely.
Because if you know how to be alone,
you'll be able to really
connect with other people.
And now that we have our phones,
people do not know how to be lonely,
they go immediately to their phone.
And the minute they start to be lonely,
they, no I don't wanna do this,
they go to their phone instead.
So they're not really
learning about themselves
the way the need to
learn about themselves.
- And then the solitude makes possible
the capacity to do conversation--
- Yes!
- Which is then
very important to the further
maturation of the self.
- Right, so I'm trying to argue now,
I mean, the challenges we face now
are challenges to privacy,
are challenges to intimacy,
are challenges to democracy,
are challenges to identity.
But are deeply challenges to,
can you put away your phone
long enough to know solitude
so then you can have relationships?
So it's not just that we face, you know,
are we gonna be human and not fall in love
with artificial intelligences,
are we gonna be just
able to be by ourselves
so that we can be with other people.
So right now it's not that
I don't like technology,
it's that I'm really worried,
it's not like an anti-technology position.
I'm worried about people.
I'm not against, I'm pro-human,
I'm not against technology,
I'm just very much pro-human.
I don't begin with an
animosity towards technology,
I'm just very concerned about human beings
and their development,
and being able to maintain
relationships with other human beings.
I don't begin with, like,
oh I'm against technology.
Technology is not kind of what's on my,
I don't begin with that.
- So what over time, as
you've studied this subject,
your concern emerges as a result of
what was a tool has turned us into a tool.
- Yeah, I mean, what was a tool,
now I don't know what
we're using the tool for.
I think we've lost our way.
When people have a moment of boredom,
and pick up their phone,
it's no longer a tool, it's
no longer a I'm using it to,
it's I'm using it to not
have a moment of boredom.
Well now it's no longer,
that's not exactly a tool exactly,
that's like a, what is that? (laughs)
- Well it's a master, it's become a--
- I don't know, it's a tool to
not have a moment of boredom,
but if a moment of boredom is a good thing
because it's helping you
develop a self and an identity
and a stable self and a set of interests
and a capacity for empathy,
then it's an underminer
of human potential.
So that's not a tool anymore,
that's an underminer.
So that's not a good thing.
- And the key here is attention, that you,
confronting the initial anxiety of boredom
and being lonely,
your attention is shifted to
another place--
- Yes.
- And data can stream
in or messages and so on
can stream in, and distract you.
- Yes, that's why I try to say,
I gave these Hitchcock lectures,
and I tried to say,
well what causes people
to get themselves into trouble?
And I tried to have, like,
something people could hold onto.
And I say it's vulnerability,
I try to boil it down.
What is it, and it's our
human, we're vulnerable.
So think about your vulnerability,
what are your vulnerabilities,
and people are vulnerable,
people are vulnerable,
they don't wanna feel vulnerable.
I try to boil it down to
something that people will
be able to sort of understand
and not feel ashamed of.
And I don't think people are necessarily
ashamed of feeling vulnerable,
I think people need to hold onto something
that they don't feel, that
they can begin to act on,
they don't feel ashamed of,
they can say yeah, that's
right, I feel vulnerable.
I don't wanna feel vulnerable.
I'm getting into trouble
'cause I don't wanna feel vulnerable.
So I don't want people to feel ashamed
that they're turning to their phone.
And I think that people
can latch onto this,
that they don't wanna feel vulnerable,
that moment of feeling
yeah, I feel anxious,
I feel alone, I feel vulnerable right now.
Like, I flew into Berkeley,
I'm allergic to something
in your air, (both laughing)
you know, I'm like ever since I got here
I'm like sniffling, I
do, I felt vulnerable.
I reached for my phone, I did.
I was like, alone in my
room, I'm like crying,
I'm like, sniffling, I'm weeping.
I reach for my phone.
Because all my friends are on my phone,
my family's on my phone,
everybody that's nice
to me is on my phone.
Okay, that's exactly what we do now
when we feel, when we're
weeping and we're sneezing,
we reach for our phone.
It's like that is what we do.
And that's fine, except if we you know,
do it all the time. (laughing)
And if a person is available,
we don't turn to the person.
And more and more, instead
of turning to the people,
we turn to our phones.
My students don't wanna
come and talk to me,
they'd rather send me a
message on their phone,
my phone, everybody wants
to be not vulnerable
because if they see me in person,
I could ask them a question
that would make them feel vulnerable.
- You're concerned now about the societal
and political consequences.
- Yes, very.
- You touched on that a minute ago.
I mean, we know that with
regard to social media
that all this data is being collected
and I get the sense from reading you
that what is being created
is a definition of you
based on all the data
that is in some ways in conflict
with who you are or may wanna be.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that
we saw in our last election
that there's a version of
you that's been scraped
and available and that,
or Brexit, you know.
This data gets sold to actors that have
plans and desires and agendas
that are very specific.
And very powerful,
and really can shape our futures
and the future of the planet.
And we're vulnerable
because now you can have
you know, there are incredible things
that artificial intelligence
and altered reality can do,
you can have any political figure
look at though they're saying anything.
You can have Barack Obama look as though
he's making a speech that's anti-Semitic.
I mean, just his face and his mouth,
I mean you can have
anybody saying anything.
- So what--
- So that you can target,
you can target him, forget
the expression fake news,
you can have any figure,
any music figure from music,
or art, or literature, saying anything,
in a completely convincing
way, and target that message,
to people who you know from what they shop
and where they go and what they do
and who they associate with.
And have people who you know,
they can be influenced by
saying anything to them.
This is scary, and we just--
- Very, very.
- Very very scary, and
people will do this now.
And we just need to be
on a different kind of
alert in this new world.
- So you feel vulnerable,
your attention is captured
by what you see online,
and that in turn fortifies what could be
very negative aspects of your own persona.
- Yeah, but I mean, one of the things
is that we've signed onto a system
where we're used to
getting things for free.
In other words, you get
Google Mail for free,
you get Maps for free,
you get Docs for free,
you get Facebook for free,
now why are you getting all this for free?
You're getting it for free
because they're taking everything,
they're reading your mail,
they're reading your docs,
they're reading what you post.
That's why it's free, it's not free.
You've agreed that they
can read all your mail,
they can read all your docs,
and they can know where you go.
That's not free.
So why it was so important to
the founders of this country
that the mail, the US mail, be protected.
That was very important.
And I remember my grandmother,
I write about this in Alone Together,
it was very interesting,
I mean there she is,
a Jewish woman
from a pogrom background,
and she takes me down to
the mailboxes in Brooklyn
and she teaches me that the
reason we're in this country
is that nobody can tamper with our mail.
Because she knows what it means
to have people tamper with your mail.
And she says we're in this country,
now she knows about J. Edgar Hoover,
I don't wanna say that
it was a perfect system,
I mean, but basically that's
what she teaches her granddaughter,
that's what she chooses to teach me.
That we're in this country
because these mailboxes,
that's what America is,
it's in the mailboxes.
So that was my citizenship lesson.
Now, what can I teach my daughter,
I say this in my book, what
can I teach my daughter about?
About email, when I know that
anybody can read her email.
Anybody can read her Facebook,
anybody can look at
what she's doing online.
It's all owned by the
people who provide it.
- One final question, so,
it's fair to say that a step
in resisting I guess is the word
is consciousness of the implications--
- Yes.
- Of all
that's happening to us.
- Yes, that's,
and I think that this is the biggest step
because people, it's like global warming,
this is like massive forgetting.
People, this is the thing that
people most want to forget.
You can watch them forgetting.
As soon as you talk to them about it,
you can watch them, you
can, (laughs) you know,
I'm a crack interviewer, I
can watch them forgetting
as I'm interviewing them about it.
Because nobody wants to be reminded,
I say, do you know, let's
talk about your Gmail?
You know, you know that it's (groans).
(laughing)
So yeah, I'm about being a
pain right now for everybody,
and reminding everybody.
- Well on that note (Sherry laughing)
and in a positive sense,
Sherry, I wanna thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.
- For being on our show.
- It's been a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation in history.
(mysterious electronic music)